[Musique]
chaque jour près de 800 couverts sont
servis ici aux élèves demi pensionnaires
la cantine scolaire du collège bourbon
est une cantine autonome c'est donc une
cuisine qui réalise sur place les menu
du déjeuner est aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la journée mondiale de la pêche
artisanale le chef a mis le poisson pays
à l'honneur dans ses assiettes
aujourd'hui la proposer trois variantes
de poisson ça reste du projet remet
aujourd'hui en papillote de points soit
des épices de noël préparation marie da
cruz a fait ce matin on ce texte pareil
au stack mariné et aussi aux roches est
de tout faire découvrir et apprécier le
poisson pays à ces jeunes collégiens
c'est d'abord lui donner du goût à la
préparation mais également travailler sa
présentation qui parfois peut surprendre
café des projets de poisson
cette journée de promotion vise à donner
plus de place aux poissons pays dans les
assiettes des établissements et
sensibiliser les élèves à cette filière
de pêche locale de 12 sur les 2300 17
tonnes de poissons pêchés en 2016 785
sont partis pour l'exportation sur les
1054 tonnes disponibles sur le marché
local seulement deux tonnes sont
consommées dans les cuisines scolaires
une part de marché que le département et
l'association réunionnaise
interprofessionnelle de la pêche et de
l'aquaculture souhaite développer
[Musique]